you know markets are is portrayed as
cold profits before people whereas you
know free markets are quite the opposite
they bring about cooperation they break
down berries succeed by meeting the
needs and wants of others you may not
love your neighbor but you want to sell
to your neighbor hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're sitting
down with Steve Forbes he's the
journalist writer analyst and
recidivists presidential candidate Steve
Forbes thanks for talking with reason TV
good to be with you Nick just to get it
out of the way are you going to run for
2016 for the president no I'm an
agitator I'm the only one not running
exercise this time now one of the things
that you really mainstreamed in American
political discourse particularly in
presidential races was the idea of the
flat tax going back you know almost 20
years we have at least two versions of a
flat tax that have been put into play by
Rand Paul by candidates Rand Paul and
Marco Rubio what do you think of their
flat tax plans and where did they you
know where did they depart from where
they should be going well take Rubio
he's put a plan out there but it has two
rates instead of one and when you put
two tax rates together it's like putting
two rabbits together they will multiply
we should have learned that from 1986
when we got it down to two rates within
a few years it was the weeds were
growing again so you got to do one
because if you have one and you want to
make a change you can't say oh that guy
will pay you won't right and if you're
gonna make a change the simplicity is
its best defense if you're gonna make a
change everyone sees what you're doing
whereas with a current coat today you
can put something in will be two years
before somebody discovers it saying on
the Rubio plan which was also
co-sponsored by Mike Lee the Utah
senator there's also a child tax credit
in that that's vastly expanded from
$1,000 to $2,500 and that there's no
income cap on that are you know with
that blows something like according to
various scores two trillion dollars in
revenue problems is does that muddy the
problem too yes it's a form of social
engineering you know it's one thing to
have basic exemptions you should be
allowed to keep a certain amount of
income to meet the necessities of life
like
back to the code in 1913 but the idea
that you can have try to get people to
have more kids by having a generous
creditor this will appeal to the middle
class or some such thing it was wrong it
does not help the economy and
experiences of other countries show if
you're pro population it's not gonna do
much there and I guess you were also
pointing I mean there's a moral
dimension to this too it's social
engineering that shouldn't be done by
the tax code it shouldn't be done by the
government at all it's usually a bad
idea one it creates a political special
interest who's against housing well now
you've got one of the most powerful
lobbies in the country so in terms of
and Puspa
the Rubio plan the 35% rate under the
current code you reach is an individual
or a couple reach the 35% rate around
$400,000 a year under his plan if you're
a single at 75,000 if you're a couple
filing it's one hundred and fifty
thousand so for a lot of taxpayers it's
gonna be a tax increase so talk about
the brand Paul plan what do you think
about that well I think it's a good step
in the right direction and to be
applauded putting a serious plan out
there with a single rate and there I
think then would it what is his rated
fourteen and a half percent he has a
fourteen F percent rate but he keeps in
charity and mortgages and because the
lobbies are so strong why do I pick a
fight with them I think the way you get
around that but nobody seems to picked
up on it is you give people a choice you
can have a pure flat tax and say you
want that or if you want to put yourself
through the the tortures of the old code
you can keep the old code Hong Kong as a
variation of that they have a
progressive system I love this
progression two to twenty percent or a
flat 16 percent but you make the choice
so if you're hung up on deductions you
can do it also takes a huge political
argument away they can't frighten you oh
we're gonna destroy housing destroyed
Charities and everything else what it
does do is say don't trust us see for
yourself which one is better
clearly everybody I mean and this is
from you know Barack Obama to Mitch
McConnell and everybody and
queen is saying I mean it's clear that
we need to redo the tax code
you know 1986 was the last comprehensive
overhaul whether they get to a flat tax
or not what has to happen for that kind
of political consensus I mean we have a
consensus that it needs to change but
what has to happen for things to
actually start moving the way you get
something moving on something is
fundamentalist taxes is to get it in the
public arena for debate that's why I'm
delighted that Senator Rand Paul's put a
proposal out delighted that senator Cruz
in favor of the flat tax apparently the
governor walker is Governor Kasich is
because if you have it out there and
then you kind of a debate then you can
refine it most importantly you get the
mandate when Ronald Reagan ran in 1980
he vigorously campaigned on a 30%
across-the-board tax cut ended up
getting 25 percent from Congress the
reason he got 25 is he had the mandate
so if he had gone out with a mild
milquetoast proposal he'd have ended up
with virtually nothing what is the
function of the tax code in America I
mean in a sense we never seem to talk
about the idea that well you know taxes
are the price we pay for government
nobody is even pretending that they
would be able to raise the revenue for
the amount of outlays that government is
making you know how do we bring that
into this conversation well the thing
the way you discuss the something like a
flat tax is it will raise revenue and
then the debate should be what you do
with the revenue but with a vibrant
economy hongkong with their very low
rates as a look over time their growth
the government revenue has been
phenomenal not from crushing people of
allowing people to flourish the key
thing on that is revenue you can get
question is what should be the spending
where should the resources go with those
are the resources be applied to and then
those are two separate debates and
that's the key thing to keep in mind
because they throw Oh might increase the
deficit well if you spend enough yes it
will well speaking of deficits John
Kasich Governor of Ohio who is also
obviously running for president he's
going around talking a lot about a
balanced budget amendment he's got
pretty good credentials on this when he
was in the House in the late 90s he
helped broker a bunch of balanced budget
deals that
came out of Washington what do you think
of the balanced budget amendment as a
concept or is the devil always in the
details well a balanced budget amendment
in the Constitution I mean as a capital
expenditure to be confused with a
regular everyday expenditure building a
battleship versus of buying a pencil so
and then terms of balance that the
danger there is if you can become a tax
increase vehicle we must balance it well
I'm not going to touch this program or
that program and suddenly you find that
but do we have that I mean is that is
that to worry be given the fact that we
don't you don't need a balanced budget
amendment okay to put Washington's
finances in order and the way you put
Washington's finances and orders not
what the Republicans did 20 years ago
and they got control of Congress they
started to chip away at this program
that program it's like World War one
trench warfare
you take the readout and then you get
the counter-offensive which happened in
1996 and kablooey the way you do is go
first after the big things that's where
having personal accounts and Social
Security you're turning a liability into
an asset and it's popular among young so
what about Medicare because I don't care
we're beginning to lurch into it in a
very messy way but we don't have real
free markets in health care we have
pieces of it but not in real free
markets proof of it is if you go to a
clinic or hospital and you ask an
advance what it costs get a strange look
it means either you're running shorter
area lunatic why would you want to know
the price now can you imagine coming to
a hotel or restaurant not caring about
the pricing let Medicare worry about it
do we need to get rid of Medicare no
what you need to do is get the patient
in charge of Medicare then the thing
that starts to take care of itself right
now in terms of health care in America
you the patient are not the customer
it's the third party whether it's
private or government and we have a
third party which is why when you go to
the hospital you have those crazy gowns
that are always that look 80 years old
he can't feel time in the back no hotel
would give you a robe like that and if
they had to compete with you as a
patient custom
they wouldn't what is really different
what what needs to happen I mean I think
a lot of people are totally on board
with the idea of bringing markets to
healthcare it creates competition it
create it will innovate choice and what
creates more healthcare right yep
markets allowed to work free markets
always turn scarcity into abundance so
what has to happen for that to happen
you know what has to change because both
with Obama care where you have now
people who are not even paying their own
insurance premiums so it's kind of like
a fourth payer is that at the taxpayer
in the subsidy system but then beyond
that it's you know how do we get to a
place where you're actually shelling out
your own money except for big-ticket
items there are various ways you go
about it one is having nationwide
competition for insurance policy I live
in New Jersey I can get a perfectly good
one at half the price in Pennsylvania
because they don't have as many idiot
regulations as New Jersey does so you
have that kind of competition clear out
mandates you should be able to choose
what you want and one of the things that
Obama's doing is helping destroy
employer-provided healthcare putting
more and more as employers are doing
anyway on the consumer giving you the
consumers in by de facto is going to be
getting more and more power and one of
the things that markets will respond to
is you don't have to pay twenty five
thousand dollars a year for a family
policy we can give you one that covers
accidents the diseases and the like for
a third of that and you may have to pay
for the filling in your tooth but you
know you're covered right now even if
you have a catastrophe your insurance
won't cover all of it so you're in favor
you're saying meadow bomber care is
having a good effect that right
unintended yeah so we're not going back
to what we had before where I can have
Obamacare which is imploding in and of
itself
you know adverse selection beginning to
kill the thing so just don't get sick
for three or four years or we sort this
thing out well the other big annual item
in the budget is the defense budget
which is coming in at what six hundred
billion this year are there abouts you
know give or take a bit how much should
that be cut those who advocate a
single-payer system the response should
be we have a single-payer system it's
called the Pentagon you like their
procurement
system that were and we can have that in
healthcare but in terms of health terms
of Defense I believe that's the first
function of government is to defend the
realm but you you certainly you're not
saying that every dollar that the
Pentagon gets it spends wisely quite the
opposite
even if we need more resources you take
the procurement system it's a disaster
for example I used to have the oversight
board for Radio Free Europe and radio
Liberty back in the Reagan and Bush
administration's for peculiar reasons we
were considered a private corporation
even though we're funded by Congress and
Delaware therefore we did not come under
the rules of procurement of the federal
government so when we ordered a
transmitter we could do it at a fraction
of the price The Voice of America not
because our engineers are better
although we thought they were they
didn't have to fill a room with all
these books and regulations reinventing
wheels reinventing blight bulbs and
everything else and so we could bring it
at a fraction but what they had to do so
if you modernize procurement and so over
so the f-35 put aside with them whether
it's a crappy plane which everybody did
seem that but but but the cost per copy
is preposterous one a procurement of
weapon system when you look at the
valley and high technology should be a
matter of months or years I mean they do
complicated new great products in a
fraction of the time and when they
really need to get something done in
defense you have what they call skunk
works you pull it out of the current
system put it aside and say go to it and
they get it done yeah so a radical
reform of procurement these seem like I
mean so basically you're talking okay
you know tax reform entitlement reform
defense reform or auditing of
procurement
why aren't you know these seem to be
natural things for a Republican Party
presidential candidate to be talking
about to be foregrounding to be leading
with you know the the Republican Party
says that it's party of limited
government of effective government and
of small government what has happened to
the Republican Party where they don't
seem to be talking about this they want
to save Medicare they want to preserve
Medicare they want to preserve Social
Security they want to whatever one of
the things that's happened really even
before the New Deal is the Left learned
how to occupy the high
or ground so we may be inefficient we
may be wasteful we end up sometimes
doing more harm than good but our hearts
are in the right place and those are
against us are against people you know
markets always portrayed as cold profits
before people whereas you know free
markets are quite the opposite they
bring about cooperation they break down
barriers succeed by meeting the needs
and wants of others you may not love
your neighbour but you want to sell to
your neighbour so it brings out the best
in human nature now human nature is a
many-faceted so what the Republicans
though are there so so what they what
the Republicans have to learn it's not
just Republicans
politicians follow they don't lead where
the intellectual movement has to be and
this is where breakthroughs in education
where you can get around the professore
yet in terms of education make these
points about what what free markets are
really about and so if you're going into
business which a lot of people do you
don't see it as something somehow
tainted even though it produces goods
produces the stuff it's somehow not
quite a moral system no it is a moral
system but that has to be taught and
that's why you have this phenomenon of
great entrepreneurs going off to the
left they don't they don't they don't
connect to understand the wellspring of
what made them possible in 2016 who do
you like obviously you're gonna vote for
Hillary in the end but before that what
what Republican candidates do you think
are particularly not just likely to win
but are actually twelve you wonder
what's happened is with the sixteen or
sixteen hundred whatever the final
number is what's going to eventually
happen is it's forcing this is where we
see with Senator Rand Paul putting out
his proposal others are going to be
doing the same it's forcing people to
put something out there to distinguish
themselves from others it's not enough
to say I don't like my other 15
competitors right what are you offering
and one of the things I think the the
base has learned from 2012 with Mitt
Romney is it's not enough to criticize
what is going on what are you going to
do one of the things Reagan did was
always put out the positive thing here's
where we can move forward so it brings
people in you
mentioned Rand Paul a few times is he
kind of your favorite at this point no
I'm looking at the whole whole field he
was want to put out the first
comprehensive tax proposal then senator
Rubio and who also is becoming a factor
so I want to see one what they're gonna
be putting out there and then - given
the bias of the old strain mainstream
media who can show they can withstand
the heat know when you get boxed around
one of the things that Reagan did was
show he could withstand the pressure one
of the interests in things in 2012 you
mentioned Mitt Romney after he lost in
what was clearly a winnable election the
GOP various people did an autopsy in
that one of the things that they noted
was that in 2004 George W Bush and his
reelection campaign got 44% of the
Hispanic vote Mitt Romney got 27% of the
Hispanic vote despite speaking Spanish
and actually being I guess born or
raised in Mexico for part of his
childhood they in this section in the
GOP autopsy about the 2012 election they
said look you know if you if Hispanics
here you are not welcome in this country
they're not gonna listen to the rest of
the sentence Donald Trump who has
emerged as a kind of gadfly in the
Republican nomination process has just
you know he's talked about Mexicans as
mostly being rapists and criminals and I
don't know he said you know maybe some
of them are decent people you know we'll
give them that what is going on with the
GOP both in terms of an inability it
seems to acknowledge you know Hispanics
or immigrants as adding to the American
kind of experiment and you know what
what what happens with that what
why has the the party of Reagan has gone
from being a very Pro immigration party
to being very hostile to the idea of
immigration well I think you know what
you're gonna find with the 16 or 18
candidates is most of them are in favor
of outreach Rand Paul has made it a
point Jeb Bush and is even though he
knows he's gonna be vulnerable on the
issue spoke Spanish which he does
extremely well and in his opening
campaign speech in his announcement so
it's not a monolith now the Democrats
are gonna try to portray as a this time
a war
Mexicans right so last time it was war
against women this time or against me
and but I think whoever emerges as a
candidate is gonna recognize you got to
go out and make your appeal for example
in 2012
once Romney knew he got the nomination
he should have gone to senator Rubio and
said design an immigration proposal and
I'll be with you on it and then steady
left left himself open to vulnerable
attack and not to mention two months
where the Democrats could run trash add
some two hundred million dollars and the
GOP doesn't respond so they paint you if
you allow your opponents to paint you
you're done well you got to do your own
agenda Hillary Clinton is you know has
an air of an inevitability around her of
course she did in 2008 and it didn't
work out but I mean at this point it
doesn't we don't see the Barack Obama on
the horizon
what is Hillary most vulnerable on she's
vulnerable on a third term of Barack
Obama
people sense this is why there's this
hoopla on the Democratic Party uh
Elizabeth Warren apparently she's not
going to run but people there's a
populist strain out there not populist
range so much as people recognize and
they can't put a finger on it
things are something's not working
something's not right so I see this
minimum wage movement even though you
can show on paper it's gonna destroy
this and hurt the very people you're
supposed to be helping the people sort
of feel we've got to do something
they're forced it's not wearing maybe
you've got to force it to work we saw
the same thing in the 1930s and even
though government was the villain it's
the the markets get the rap for it right
so the the key thing here whether it's
in terms of appealing to people is
honing your message and going after and
asking for supports like making a sale
you're not gonna buy my product most of
the time unless I've gone out and
persuaded you this is something you got
to have do you think Donald Trump is a
negative influence in American politics
what he's done is tap a strain the
strain of things are not working in the
sense of even take immigration for Perle
immigration reform and but why when we
know somebody is a criminal
normally a deport
why do you have sanctuary people feel
where the laws aren't being enforced and
we wear our voice is not being heard so
he's tapped into and what he's forcing
others to do is say all right how do we
really move forward on this and make
your case in a way you know take the
greatest one of the great chief in
American politics go back to the 1850s
Abraham Lincoln running in Illinois
southern Illinois even though they was
very Pro South Road they greatly feared
abolition and the idea of a cheap black
labor competing and you know you the
whole thing and so how do you make your
case against Stephen Douglas who says oh
I'm for democracy if you want to vote
slavery and go ahead you know isn't that
the Democratic way to make the case even
without social media without TV or radio
that know why is slavery wrong and why
you should even if we may not like the
black man you better be concerned about
slavery and the spread of slavery how it
affects you tough to do but he figured
out ways to do it and so he can take
seemingly tough things this is not a
great example because he ended up losing
the election because he thought he had
it won but back in 1948 Tom Dewey got in
a debate with his principle opponent
over should they make illegal the
Communist Party most Americans say this
is a threat why why well why should we
make it legal
do we defended it and won the primary
defending it because they had a debate
and he marshaled the argument and he
said that it's yeah it's a bad thing but
in America you're allowed to think he
made the tough case and Lincoln learned
it from peeling the jury up in the
middle of the night figuring out how do
I make this case to the jury in a way in
which though they'll come around to my
point of view and in that if I'm
remembering correctly he talked about
how well today we say that the black man
is not the equal of the of the white and
shouldn't have the same rights and then
tomorrow it'll be the immigrant or the
Catholic etc and kind of showed yes and
if you can make a black man a slave why
can't a white man make you a slave
that's happening yeah but it took
articulation cuz there's a real fear out
there speaking of another hard case
thankfully one that's not in the United
States let's turn to Greece which is
melting down as we speak a lot of people
tend to look at
the troika or the Europe the mass of
European countries or the European
Central Bank saying they're right and
Greece is wrong
others say Greece's you know Greece
deserves more time or more slack you
tend to talk about this as that there
are not a hero and villain here what
should what's your take on Greece both
parties in that case are wrong the
troika
there are version of austerity is
falling on the private sector raise the
money reduce the deficit raise taxes in
Greece national sales tax equivalent the
v80 23% payroll tax we have a 15 in this
country 45 now wonder people don't pay
it so they crush whatever is left of the
private and they're saying in austerity
it should be that government spending
gets cut but not taxes given the the the
the public sector takes a hit and you
reduce taxes simplifying Greece to
Greece's neighbors Bulgaria and
Macedonia have 10 percent flat taxes
they have troubles because Europe's in
trouble but their economies are a whole
lot better than the the economy of
Greece so you want a pro-growth program
now Britain they didn't boast about it
because I guess it doesn't appeal to
voters but in the fire five years of the
Conservative government for whatever its
flaws they reduced the number of public
sector workers from 6.3 million to 5.3
million and and they're plainly doing
their 700,000 in the next five years
that is meaningful
that's what Greece is not done Greece
still has more bureaucrats per capita
than any other country in Europe so you
go for pro-growth and that's how you
restructure things and make things
happen so all of Europe is getting
crushed by taxation Japan is getting
crushed by that should Greeks creditors
though should they be calling all their
loans or them will you
but what Greek creditors should be doing
is figuring out if you are credited to
the banks figure out how do I get equity
and reorganize the banks in an economy
that's reorganized where we have growth
again and will will come out just fine
Greeks when they leave Greece do very
well very successful here Australia and
elsewhere so they have that
entrepreneurial spirit from the younger
the Mediterranean going thousands of
years back well that is reminiscent of
another hot spot in the
in the global economy China where you
know under communism Chinese people in
China were poor everywhere else in the
world they were doing well so we know
it's the institution's the kind of
economic frameworks political frameworks
what's your take on what's happening in
China we've seen like incredible
volatility and drops in the Chinese
stock market and it looks like the
economy may be imploding what what what
do you think well in the stock market
it's going up 150% so going down 30 or
40 is not hardly in 1929 but China is
having - one day I think the one hand
realized I got to make reforms they got
to liberalize the capital markets they
have 44 million small businesses which
make up two-thirds of the economy but
they're sort of in the twilight zone in
terms of Finance so they've got to make
changes there then the other hand they
don't like the stock market to drop
because I think it reflects badly on the
government so they've they've got the
this ongoing tension that they've got to
work out Milton Friedman used to say
that economic economic freedom ended up
leading towards political freedom
because as if you liberalized economies
and dictators and tyrants were more
willing to open up the economy before
the political process but then when
people get rich they start lobbying for
political rights do you think that's
happening in China where as a rising
middle class comes on they they want to
have more transparency they want to have
simpler and more open government it's
not so much even basic about government
is if I'm allowed to make choices on
what job I take where I live what I own
what I buy what I sell well why should I
have to put up with this idiot commissar
who was a mucking things up and so what
if one thing leads to the other now one
of the reasons why you've seen this
crackdown in China in recent years is
precisely these forces are rising up how
do you contain them and that's what they
haven't quite figured out yet so yes
Friedman ultimately is right and the key
thing is what you want to encourage
China to do without looking like an
imperialist is continuing with reforms
where you're going to get more of these
tensions in the future and the fact that
the capital is leaving China shows that
people are not convinced that the
government's going to work it out so
they want to hedge their bets and so
yeah
the fact that Chinese have capital to
export is a testament to what the
country's done in the last 35 years and
so you want those reforms to continue if
you want to have Shanghai's of a capital
center when the reason why Hong Kong has
done so well even after the turnover is
they still have a court system where
people are trust that in terms of
commercial law commercial disputes
rather than Shanghai so you if you want
to be a center you've got to have all
the partners of what we have here and in
more sophisticated capital markets
commercial law so you can resolve these
disputes without having it being a party
matter so but life is never simple it's
always looks messy okay well that's a
good way to end it I want to thank you
Steve Forbes for talking to Reason TV
thank you for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]